G1
[Música]
é
o nome é a capa do nosso ser eu aprendi
isso com as filosofias africanas então
eu vou começar me apresentando muito
prazer eu sou assim Gere Professora
Doutora
pesquisadora e uma índia eu sou um
acendedor de sóis eu estudo a África e
Afro diáspora desde os meus 18 anos
comecei Na graduação ou doutorado com as
literaturas africanas e recentemente com
pós-doutoramento em filosofia africana
foram nessas andanças por África e suas
e as cores que eu conheci a filosofia
bakongo ou filosofia que indese que é
uma filosofia bantu dos povos de bakongo
da região que a gente conhece como
Kangoo e Angola mais que a gente também
vê materializado aqui nas práticas de
terreiros de matriz africana e como
Candomblé e Umbanda
e a filosofia bakongo diz que todo mundo
todo ser humano é um salvo e é
responsabilidade da comunidade
acender o nosso sol para o nosso livre
caminhar na vida
e veja durante esse percurso de África e
diáspora Eu também me entende comuns ao
vivo e isso foi decisivo para o meu
caminhar porque afinal eu era uma jovem
mãe periférica estudante que queria ser
professora então entender o outro como
os ao vivo fazia parte desse caminho de
Magistério que eu queria tomar mas
Sobretudo o fato de mato e gestar o meu
filho Rodrigo desde os meus 17 anos foi
decisivo para minha escolha
dessa forma eu consigo ver a minha
família com uma constelação solar
Subindo a Montanha Da Vida
E é claro que eu consigo falar com o
sobre isso sim com um distanciamento do
tempo e muita terapia É mesmo mas o mais
importante que eu tenho a dizer vocês é
que eu busquei nas filosofia bakongo a
matéria filosófica de pesquisa para
entender a solar idade da nossa
humanidade aqui no Brasil e foi assim
que eu cheguei a pesquisa de reflexões
artístico filosóficas sobre a humanidade
nega em que eu tinha um desafio que era
saber a quantas andam o brilho do nosso
sol nós afro-brasileiros aqui no Brasil
e aí eu tinha um grande desafio porque
para medir a nossa solar idade eu
precisava questionar o que era
Humanidade para nossa sociedade e de
alguma forma eu tive que ir pensar sobre
o ocidente porque afinal o Brasil não é
ocidente mas ele p a forma uma categoria
ocidental e América Latina de forma que
eu vou explicar para vocês o que é
ocidente rapidamente ocidente é um
fenômeno de ser e estar no mundo é uma
forma de ser e estar no mundo que é
essencialmente ângulo europeia
entretanto por causa do capital e
sobretudo da indústria cultural queriam
se sociedades ocidentalizadas
justamente como a nossa então é
importante também dizer que o ocidente
ele possui três pilares básicos
o primeiro Pilar é o Pilar
judaico-cristão
responsável pelos nossos entendimentos
de moral essa ideia de singularidade da
Verdade ou ainda essa ideia de Deus
único verdadeiro somente aquele que a
gente conhece bem o segundo Pilar é o
Pilar greco-romana
responsável por Oi Solange a sociedade
democracia educação mas também
colonialismo e imperialismo
Oi e o terceiro Pilar é o Pilar
Iluminista aquele que elege a razão como
critério único e último e aplica o
paradigma de injuntivo que diz associa
razão e emoção e os bárbaros dos
civilizados
E aí é importante também dizer que os
estudos decoloniais tem uma categoria
para o Regente dessa máquina ocidental
desse modelo civilizatório que o
ocidente impõe as suas sociedades mas
também as sociedades ocidentalizadas
então para os estudos decoloniais esse
Regente da supremacia ocidental se chama
Senhor do acidente e aí eu tinha um
desafio eu precisava localizar os nossos
senhores do ocidente e aí eu fui pensar
numa escala de humanidade ocidental mas
para pensar nessa escala enquanto alguém
que pesquisava caminhos e
filosóficos de uma cidade negra eu
precisei ir ao audiovisual e eu fui
buscar uma metáfora de um personagem
metafórico que servisse de exemplo a
esse arquétipo do senhor dos dentes e
foi assim que eu fui até a obra o lobo
de Wall Street de Martin scorcese um
filme premiado de 2013 espero que vocês
tenham visto se não viram fica a dica
esse filme tem um personagem principal
que se chama Jordan Belfort
interpretado pelo ator Leonardo DiCaprio
e esse personagem ele é de certa forma a
metáfora
cinematográfica desse Senhor do ocidente
sabe por quê primeiro ele é um homem
branco
depois ele é morador do eixo Norte
possui poder financeiro econômico
capital político e cultural não tem
empatia pela outridade esse ainda
esportes porque eu quero que vocês vejam
filmes ele realmente rege A Dominação
ocidental naquele cenário então
basicamente o que eu precisei fazer a
entender que um para a sociedade você
dentais e ocidentalizadas a humanidade a
nossa humanidade ela é considerada de
acordo com que você se aproxima ou se
distancia
dinamicamente do Senhor do acidente é
isso se chama escala de humanidade
ocidental eu precisei criar essa escala
para poder saber qual é o nível da nossa
solar idade aqui assinar o Brasil é uma
cópia mal-diagramado do acidente Então
como é que nós
todos nós estamos localizados em termos
de humanidade nessa escala porque veja o
modelo de humanidade que predomina sobre
nós é o senhor ocidente e todos nós
vamos Subindo ou descendo nessa escala
de acordo com o nosso gênero arrasta
nosso poder econômico financeiro a
cultura que partilhamos o território que
vivemos a língua que falamos
Esses são só alguns exemplos dos fatores
que te jogam para cima ou para baixo
nessa humanidade e que sobretudo
reconhece ou não e as humanidade a sua
solar idade e aí é importante Dizer para
vocês que o Brasil também tem os seus
senhores
Vocês conseguem perceber quem são os
senhores do acidente aqui aquelas
pessoas que tem o modelo de verdade
única de Deus único sexualidade única
família única
e aí é interessante também entender que
esse cenário que também é imposto a nós
porque como eu falei nós somos uma
sociedade ocidentalizada nós vivemos na
lógica do acidente só que a nossa
sociedade aqui no Brasil ela é composta
por 108 milhões de afrodescendente o que
nos faz ser a maior diáspora africana do
mundo vocês sabiam disso
56, 10 por cento dos brasileiros são
afrodescendentes
Oi e aí então dentro desse cenário
pensando a nossa solar idade como é que
a gente pode que caminhos a gente pode
pensar ali para o nosso brilho
diante desse desafio eu precisei me
perguntar como é que nós
afro-descendentes nos tornamos
afro-brasileiros E aí eu fui até uma
socióloga americana chamada Maria Ivani
e o seu conceito de massa você sabe o
que é massa
a massa é um fenômeno de poder e de
desumanização
que assola pessoas negras no mundo ele
começa com a invasão ou continente
Africano para fingir dominação passa
pelo sequestro
encarceramento volta na árvore do
esquecimento
embarque
travessia desembarque leilão
escravidão
pós-escravidão
favelização
guetificação
e atualmente o genocídio negro com seus
múltiplos tentáculos
e essa essa diáspora e essa massa que
nos assola porque afinal nós
afro-brasileiros fomos fundados também
na massa na verdade as viagens foram as
negras na América foram fundadas na
marra ou seja não nos foi dado a
perceber uma vitalidade solar que não
seja na experiência da desumanização
da massa
e é muito interessante porque amarrar
Ela traz negociações mas ela também traz
estratégias então é bem possível que
pessoas negras que estejam me ouvindo
consigam identificar a desumanização do
estado da mafa essa práxis nos
interstícios das nossas relações de
desumanização social nós conseguimos
identificar tanto nas nossas trajetórias
quanto na trajetória das nossas famílias
É mas o mais importante nisso tudo é que
nós estamos bem conseguimos identificar
Quais foram as nossas estratégias e
ferramentas de resistência
permanência e continuidade porque veja
bem alma a fé ela também é fundada a
partir de um barco porque veja o barco
dos nossos ancestrais
desembarcaram no Brasil mas esse barco
poderia ter desembarcado em qualquer
território da América e aí nós seríamos
a família anos afro chilenos
afro-cubanos
afro-argentinos porque não mas não somos
afro-brasileiros porque o nosso barco o
barco dos nossos ancestrais desembarcou
aqui Oi e aí interessante observar a
maneira como nós não se está em chegaram
ele chegaram para a desumanização da
massa portando o corpo a palavra e o
conjunto filosófico cultural
ético e estético E são essas as
ferramentas utilizadas por nós
afrodiaspóricas na América nos últimos
500 anos para resistir à desumanização
do estado da massa
e dentre essas ferramentas chegou a
filosofia bakongo a arte de ser uns ao
vivo e essa Filosofia é praticada desde
então aqui por nós porque é uma
filosofia que nos lembra que o principal
é ter fé na vida e que a nossa
humanidade ela é inegociável não tem
recorte não tem exceção e não tem porém
então quando a gente passa assim
entender como só as vivos Nós também
Fazemos o movimento de sankofa para o
passado para buscar outros valores
trazidos pelos nossos ancestrais e nesse
torno para o presente para plantar as
pedras do amanhã nós encontramos o
matriarcado o aquilombamento a
ancestralidade à ludicidade a
corporeidade a força vital com valores
de permanência continue o e resistência
Então é assim que eu chego aqui nesse
Tex sabendo que a África e diáspora me
ensinou a ser pluriversal então diante
de vocês que estão de certa forma
estranhos a mim a essa história e até
mesmo estranho usar o estado da
desumanização da mafa eu quero dizer que
o trabalho enquanto uma acendedora de
sóis e uma forma de romper
essa dinâmica genocida assim você pode
buscar qualquer ferramenta do meu
trabalho do meu canal no YouTube os meus
artigos acadêmicos o meu livro infantil
ou até mesmo ser meu aluno na
universidade a base é uma só e te
lembrar que as humanidades ainda
negociar veu e que a gente precisa
derrubar o estado de desumanização
e por isso aqui para vocês que não me
conhecem eu quero dizer o seguinte nós
todos nós sem exceção somos
sóis vivos e que a nossa humanidade o
nosso bem mais precioso e de forma de
inegociabilidade não há possibilidade de
negociar a nossa humanidade porque o
principal é o valor na vida e eu quero
dizer a vocês que a arte de acender o
sol do outro é para todo mundo e que a
nossa maior responsabilidade
da vida é justamente brilhar então
trilhem obrigada
E aí